ich bin einfach zum Flughafen gesteppt
habe den ersten Langstreckenflug auf der
Anzeigetafel gebucht und bin an einem
echt krassen Ziel gelandet mittlerweile
jetzt noch krasser wie man hier sehen
kann für mich hat die Reise gestartet in
Frankfurt das ist ja der größte
Flughafen in Deutschland und neben ganz
ganz vielen Flügen nach Amerika ging
auch welche nach Soul Hongkong und
Bangkok die waren allerdings alle schon
ausgebucht der erste der wieder frei war
der nach Bangkok ich brauche die auch
kein Visum und war gegen alle
Krankheiten geimpft deswegen ging es
nach Bangkok nach ca 11 Stunden bin ich
angekommen erstmal im Hotel eingecheckt
und ein bisschen ausgeruht und dann habe
ich mich ins Nachtleben der echt
impulsiven Stadt Bangkok gestürzt und ja
wurde fast weg da bin ich dann ganz
schnell wieder abgehauen ich musste ganz
schnell weg auf jeden Fall
mittlerweile bin ich ganz alleine hier
am Strand war auf jeden Fall eine
richtig gute Entscheidung das einfach
mal zu tun würdet ihr euch das auch
trauen schreibt gerne mal in die
Kommentare